est-ce qu'on n'a pas été trop coulant
vidéo finalement avec l'utilisation de
ces moyens exceptionnels
la suède qui est un pays très voisin non
seulement le gouvernement n'a pas imposé
d'un pas interdit à ses à ses
ressortissants de de sortir d'aller au
restaurant d'aller au cinéma
les faits dont lui confiance dans leur
gouvernement
la soldate addiction qu'on leur impose
et c'est pas de rassemblement au dessus
de 50 personnes et en cas de
rassemblement au dessus de 50 personnes
des policiers ne pouvaient pas
verbalisés on voit bien qu'on est dans
un tout autre système en suède et en
france le est simplement une chose juste
avec une précision le le l'état
d'urgence sanitaire s'est caractérisée
par l'hégémonie d'un d'un principe
fondamental qui a occulté tout le reste
qui est la préservation de la vie la
présence sauver les vies était un
impératif catégorique qui s'est imposée
et qui a pendant les deux mois
totalement occulter toutes les autres
tous les autres toutes les autres
libertés des droits qui pouvaient
exister dans une démocratie et ce
principe là à une telle puissance que
tout le monde l'a appliqué les
politiques
les juges des îles locaux et ses
sentiers absolument aucune discussion
sur comment contrebalancer ce principe
fondamental par d'autres principes qui
aurait pu effectivement atténuer son
hégémonie et donc il peut réintégrer des
formes de liberté qui avait disparu de
ce fait là mais c'était un moment dans
l'état d'urgence qui aujourd'hui se
désagrège pour laisser apparaître
d'autres valeurs d'autres principes qui
vont reconstruire la vie collective
autour d'une perspective à mon avis plus
que réjouissant pour la démocratie
[Musique]